god forbid there's a woman that's
younger or prettier or more successful
than MJ MJ will annihilate them and the
fact that she's more concerned about
being seen as the villain as opposed to
being honest and coming clean is what's
the most hurtful
all right Reza yes sir before we dive in
dive the moustache a moustache it's
making a return this is not a full
stache this is just a foray back into
the potential of having a stache testing
it out again testing the marketplace
yeah okay
why are we testing the marketplace I
just thought it might be a fun you know
look for the season eight jobs reunion
it's been such an explosive season so
far
and I just thought for such a nuclear
amazing explosive season of Shahs of
Sunset that I would have to do something
that explosive and killer for the
reunion
nuclear that's a big word the episode
coming up is next-level nuclear during
my trial for my restraining order
against MJ's husband her side subpoena
that footage and it was very very very
eye-opening for me and I realized from
that raw unfiltered footage what was
happening it was really an important
thing for me to see and I'm glad I got
to see it take me into that moment why
is it so explosive so my friend of 30
years betrayed me
she was in cahoots with a little guy to
get him a job on the show he was using
innocuous memes and gifs of little porno
clips not of my husband's genitalia
things that they would send back and
forth his friends the same way I do with
some of my friends they took something
like that and turned it into something
that it wasn't an MJ fed to her little
friend that this is borderline sexual
harassment which is then what happens
when he comes to confront me it went
from being naked Jenga to he was
sexually harassed and it got super
convoluted
and I immediately knew that MJ's dirty
fingers were all over it and just to be
clear friend is ally assuring I'm not
gonna ever speak his name but MJ's new
friend she was trying to take care of
him listen MJ is a very very very smart
woman I've been friends with her for 30
years she says to people if I'm so
gangster I would have done it myself if
I wanted to confront Reza
she's gangster but she's more gangster
in that she tried to keep her hands
clean what she didn't account for was
that her new little friend would turn on
her and reveal what she was up to and
that is what she is struggling with now
okay so in this analogy you're working
with it's as if she's a mob boss no
let's break it down
Beverly Hills style okay Lucy Lucy apple
juicy destiny was Teddy Mellencamp as
soon as Teddy Mellencamp realized there
was some bullying to go down she ran
back and told everyone listen y'all I
just almost got caught up in some real
BS about Lucy Lucy apple juicy so that
would make MJ Lisa Vanderpump dogs
employee exactly I forget what the
gentleman's name Eliezer yes there you
go for the record
lisa has said she had nothing to do with
puppy gate and I'm not saying Lisa did
have anything to do with puppy gate I
was only making a comparison for the
audience to better understand a
situation that is our situation unlike
the rest of the Beverly Hills cast I
actually have all of the receipts to
prove what it is that I'm talking about
and why I terminated a 30-year
friendship there are recordings
I heard recordings I would never drop
you think I'm insane I'm gonna drop my
best friend of 30 years over here saying
you better believe that I have receipts
recordings true
no to rot like I have it in writing I
was horrified I couldn't believe what MJ
was up to she used her little friend to
talk to destiny so she never had to talk
to destiny so if it ever came back she
could always say I never spoke to
destiny no you didn't need to because
you're thirsty little friend that was
dying to be on the show would have done
anything for you and that is the
heartbreaking part that she sat there
and thought this so well planned and
orchestrated the two things she didn't
think would ever happen was that her
little friend would turn on her or that
I would ever find out you got caught
not one hand not two hands elbows deep
in the cookie jar with crumbs all over
your face we all know what you did just
say sorry it's cool we'll embrace you we
all make mistakes I don't get why
they're digging their heels in so tight
and denying denying denying in the face
of so much evidence and the fact that my
best friend of 30 years wouldn't be
smart enough to know that if me and my
husband fall out with someone that my
best friend of 30 years who I've done
more for than my own sister should also
not mess with that person there's
nothing worse that you can do than be in
cahoots with someone that has an ax to
grind between me and my husband was she
setting him up to be her minion in this
group or cuz there were rumors and
rumblings that she wasn't going to
return to the show no she was trying to
ask for more money she felt like she was
deserved more money she wanted the baby
to have money she wanted money for her
house the cleaning lady should get money
she wanted money to clean her house cut
her grass her mom wants money the bleach
for her mom's hair the red lipstick for
her mom is imported from God knows where
they wanted money for everything and
everyone and we just started shooting
and it was just like I was fighting for
her this is my boo I love her take care
of her blah blah blah blah blah I mean
you two really have been the show for
all these years the foundation that it's
built on now that things have changed
what does that feel
like for you operating still in this
world of shots I still love MJ I will
always love MJ it doesn't erase the 30
years that MJ and I have I just don't
like her right now and the fact that
she's more concerned about being seen as
the villain as opposed to being honest
and coming clean is what's the most
hurtful but I attribute it to the people
she has around her and in her here here
every person that's in MJ's life today
is someone that she met while she was on
Shahs of Sunset including her husband
and that's really sad to me and it's sad
to see money and fame affect her the way
it has is their hope for things to
course-correct they're absolutely okay
I'm 100% about owning what you've done
wrong apologizing for it and growing
from that point where do things go from
there what is still to unfold after the
pool party moment the pool party is just
the beginning actually MJ was going
around town telling every outlet that
would talk to her that I blocked her
while she was dying in the ICU what
couldn't have been further from the
truth
she and I were communicating the whole
time I was just gathering all my
information because I knew she was
behind it so I was livid I was on fire I
knew if I went to the hospital that I
would either get into a fistfight with
Tommy or some bad thing would happen you
can't show up for someone and be happy
for them when you feel like they're
doing you wrong so going to the hospital
you know was not an option for me the
way I was feeling and then I thought I
need to put this [ __ ] on ice until I
get to a calm cool place let me process
this betrayal and how I'm feeling and
when I'm ready I'll reach out to my best
friend of 30 years but that sleazeball
Nima that real opportunist sleazeball
Nemo who I will never speak to ever
again decided knowing me and MJ for only
two years that he knew best and that
maybe she should show up and force
a confrontation and I think that if I
had time to cool off process process it
more there'd be a better outcome but
because NEMA decided it was in whatever
best interest to ambush me and bring MJ
there being peaceful that [ __ ] just ran
off like the [ __ ] that he is good did
you instigate between him and Ally why
do you think MJ went along with that
because she wanted to come and defend
her behavior she was angry that nobody
came to visit her when she was in the
hospital thank God everything went well
but what she's trying to make it seem
like partly is to diffuse from all of
the she was pulling when she wasn't
almost dying the nine months when she
was on bed rest with her mom playing
battleship and trying to figure out all
her little moves this kind of
puppeteering behavior that is a lifelong
thing of MJ's a lifelong okay lifelong
thing of MJ's please ask MJ to give you
a list of six girlfriends that I knew
she was friends with in high school
where were they at her wedding
not one of them were there there's a
reason why these patterns don't go away
and there's a reason why you leave all
this carnage by the wayside she cannot
stand me being friends with other women
god forbid there's a woman that's
younger or prettier or more successful
than MJ MJ will annihilate them poor
Lilly I literally saw her at golnaz's
baby shower and I walked up to her I
hugged her and apologize to her
profusely because half of the venom that
MJ gave her was as a result of me loving
Lilly and wanting to be super close to
her poor aza
you saw what happened to aza I mean and
now destiny I can't get close to any
female it's like are you kidding me I've
known Destiny's family
longer than I've known MJ destiny wasn't
born yet when I knew Destiny's family
and MJ has a real hard time accepting
that for some reason she doesn't want
anyone to have a connection to me that
could potentially be longer than the
connection MJ has how was your and Adams
relationship impacted by all of this
mine and Adams relationship was impacted
like a 9.0 earthquake it really opened
up a bunch of wounds and it created a
lot of mistrust and both of us felt very
betrayed because MJ was both of our
confidants we treated her like a queen
like gold like she was family and to be
betrayed by someone that we were so kind
to it's really just devastating now in
hindsight it was the best thing that
could have ever happened because it's
brought Adam and I so much closer to one
another our communication is through the
roof but at a huge sacrifice you did
catch a little flak for the phone call
when she was in the ICU oh hey
Maris did you tell alia Sheree to come
confront me about sexually harassing
people that Adam has been sexually
harassing him do you regret at all
calling her in that moment absolutely
not okay absolutely not I wish that my
best friend of 30 years hadn't betrayed
me I wasn't thinking clearly
I wasn't thinking well you know if I
wait two hours she won't be in the ice
it wasn't like that on the flip side you
weren't thinking like this will make a
great TV moment you were just living
your life like I got to call her I'm so
glad you said that do you know why it
was about life it was about is my best
friend a lying conniving manipulative
person who's betraying me and coming
between my husband or is this some
innocuous thing drummed up by this
little person sitting before me
auditioning for Shahs of Sunset I know
this leads to a domino effect of
there's the Tommy drama we've seen the
footage of you I'm smashing the planters
in your yard we know a restraining order
went down yeah as all that was unfolding
in your life and now we're gonna watch
it back what are you thinking if you set
foot on my property because of something
I said at a pool party I don't care what
the hell it was I said at a pool party
if you show up at my house after calling
me on the phone and telling me you're
gonna kill me you drive up with a
baseball bat
you jump my fence and you vandalize my
property and you trespass I don't give a
flying F who you are you're gonna get in
trouble we wanted to sell our house we
wanted to move we had full time security
24/7 for a week outside of our door I
was gonna get a gun it was no joke you
say door is open to repair things with
MJ but how can you have a relationship
with MJ when her husband and the father
of her child of someone that it seems
you can never repair things when you
don't think the husband is gonna you
think she's gonna stay with that husband
you think she's gonna stay with a
husband who has no job what does Tommy
do for a living but Tommy would have to
be out of the picture I happen every
night I have a 3-year restraining order
with Tommy I'm praying that in these
three years that she and I in a safe
public location can have some sort of
dialogue where we can turn the page and
he's just her muscle I think that if she
and I can turn the page that she can
talk to her muscle and you know calm him
down if MJ does not own up to what
you're saying she needs to own up to at
the reunion in between now and a
potential Season nine yeah what does
Season nine look like can she come back
to this group why couldn't she I'm gonna
be cordial with her I'll be polite to
her I even saw her at Bravo con I said
hello MJ it's nice to see you and she
goes it's nice to see me isn't is it
it's nice and I was like and I turned
around and I went and mingled with all
the other
amazing Bravo liberties that were there
she couldn't have been more ugly she
couldn't have been more unpleasant she
was full of some issue and then the
funny thing was a couple minutes later
Mike turns to me and goes can you
believe this [ __ ] she's the one that
started all this now she doesn't want to
be nice let's talk about some lighter
more fun things yeah VG's about to be a
mom I am over the moon for GG has seen
her go through that process made you and
Adam revisit the conversations around
kids honestly what Tommy did by coming
to our house and just all the toxicity
that came our way because of MJ and
Tommy we really put the baby-making
situation on hold until I figure out
what is going on because he's very
threatening and it it scares us I have
no problem saying I am afraid of him
other happy good news Reza be obsessed
yes is selling across the country yes
and I'm proud to say that it's doing so
well that we're doing a new higher-end
24-karat collection which is in the
works which is gonna have a higher
infusion of the really expensive
ingredients that are really beneficial
like champagne and diamonds for shine
gold for strange black truffle oil for
nourishment hydrolyzed pea protein for
grow Wow yeah went from awesome with her
Diamond watered are you putting diamonds
and hair care products totally yeah when
you walk into a Sally's is there like a
little special Bravo library section
where it's recipe obsessed and then
Kenya Moore hair care next to each other
no but I'm afraid that if if we are next
to each other that that [ __ ] is gonna
roll lid I like move me to another area
and put herself on top because you know
how Kenya does I know how can you die
yeah nope all jokes aside being a gay
middle-eastern kid who wasn't born in
this country to walk into a store and
see my bottles with my name on it it
makes me feel like wow this is the
greatest country and the
world and you really really can do
whatever you want
[Music]
you